hey here's a funny voicemail um
in light of donald trump deducting 70
grand for haircut
stuff uh take a listen to this voicemail
i got
hey david this is dave from california
regarding trump's taxes i want to ask
you a personal question
would you be deducting the price of
haircuts right when you do the david
pakman show
now you know you can so will you be
doing that
you know what's funny about this so so
first of all i don't spend 70 grand on
my haircuts
i spend 35 bucks i guess every two
months so that's like you know i spent
about 225 dollars a year on haircuts
my accountant said it's one of those
things that i
can i can do it as a business expense if
i want because i'm getting haircuts for
a show
that if i were audited it could be an
area of disagreement
with an irs auditor but my accountant
says i i would probably be fine
doing that uh but no i have not done
that yet and it's just not really enough
money
to to make a difference but i i
appreciate you looking out for
getting every dollar i can in tax
deductions dave oh we've got a great
bonus show for you today get
instant access by becoming a member
at joinpackman.com one of our sponsors
is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plug-in
let you give each company a randomized
virtual credit card number that you
create out of thin air it'll even
autofill the card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances
you can create up to 12 of these virtual
credit cards a month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them
you can delete them anytime you want so
when you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over if i use a virtual credit card
number
you're keeping your identity private by
not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or credit card
info protected
against data breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but
if you want privacy also offers a ten
dollar a month plan
that gives you one percent cash back and
lets you create 36
credit cards a month and a 25 a month
plan tailored more for small businesses
where you can create
60 card numbers a month and much more
but definitely
go ahead and at least get started with
the free plan you'll protect your
financial info companies can't charge
you unexpectedly and like i said
you'll get five dollars to spend when
you sign up at
privacy.com pacman